[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Gundula
Gause und Christian
Siebers guten Abend wir können heute mal
einen Superlativ riskieren ausnahmsweise
denn die Welt steht vor einem
schicksalswahljahr noch nie waren so
viele Menschen zur Wahl aufgerufen in
Indien in den USA dazu kommen Wahlen die
zwar so heißen aber keine echte Wahl
bieten wie in Russland und Europa wählt
ein neues Parlament aus deutscher Sicht
ist das der auftagt zum Superwahljahr
2024 und für die Kanzlerpartei SPD geht
es ja man kann fast sagen um alles sie
will in der Europa Wahlkampagne auch auf
ein Gesicht setzen das selbst gar nicht
zur Wahl steht und dessen Sympathiewerte
gerade tief im Keller sind der Mann
heißt Olaf Scholz über die Parteitage
zur Europawahl von gleich zwei
ampelparteien heute berichtet Andreas
Hoppert starke Stimmen für Europa und Z
die vorwegehen sollen so der spdpl für
die Europawahl Katharina by der als
Spitzenkandidatin an ihrer Seite der
Bundeskanzler das mit den Stimmen klappt
schon ganz
gut nur Olaf Scholz schwächelt ein wenig
wir haben hier plakatiert Deutschlands
stärkste Stimmen für Europa irgendein
Virus hat mir mitgeteilt es müsste bei
der Stimme noch ein bisschen nachhelfen
irgendwie sinnbildlich für die Lage der
SPD Deutschlands Sozialdemokratie
schwächelt und leidet noch nie waren die
Umfragen so verheerend das letzte ZDF
Politbarometer verzeichnete bundesweit
historisch schlechte
13% tatsächlich war Scholz für die SPD
immer ein Zugpferd gerade im Wahlkampf
21 dieser schlussspur der hatte ganz
viel mit ihm auch als Person zu tun und
wenn wir uns jetzt seine Werte anschauen
in Umfragen dann hat sich das
tatsächlich gedreht insofern ist es
durchaus eine mutige Entscheidung mit
diesen beiden Gesichtern Scholz und Bale
in den Wahlkampf zu gehen mutig nennt es
der Parteienforscher alternativlos und
richtig sagt der
Parteivorsitzende es gehtem chen indem
wir daran arbeiten dass das Alltagsleben
der Menschen besser wird da geht es um
gute Löhne da geht es um mieten da geht
es um den kitaitapatz da geht es um den
Pflegeplatz es geht darum dass wir
Zuversicht zeigen auch aus den Protesten
auf den Straßen gegen AFD und
Gesinnungsgenossen will die SPD
verlorenegangenen Stimmen zurückholen
der Kampf gegen Rechts hierzulande und
in Europa sei schließlich marktenkern
der Partei die Europawahl ist für die
Bürger und Bürger dieses Landes eine
Chance ein klares Votum gegen abzugeben
jedes einzelne Mitglied der SPD steht in
der Tradition des Widerstandes gegen
alle Formen von Extremismus und
Menschenfeindlichkeit für ein
friedliches Zusammenleben in Freiheit
das ist es wer wir sind und das ist es
was Deutschland und Europa jetzt
brauchen andere Partei andere Farbe aber
die gleichen Probleme auch der FDP
laufen die Wähler davon so viele dass
sie momentan nicht mal in den Bundestag
käme ebenfalls in Berlin Europa
Parteitag der Liberalen sie gehen mit
Marie Agnes Strack Zimmermann als
Spitzenkandidatin ins Rennen und auch
hier steht der Kampf gegen Rechts ganz
oben auf der
Tagesordnung nie wieder das ist nicht
nur mit Blick auf die Vergangenheit ein
Appell nie wieder ist ein Auftrag für
Gegenwart und Zukunft den wir annehmen
auch die Liberalen hadern mit der Ampel
der permanente streitsorge für schlechte
Umfragen die unterschiedliche Auffassung
von Militärhilfe für die Ukraine ärgert
die FDP Spitzenkandidatin
besonders wie gehen wir eben mit den
Krisen in der Welt um da wünschte ich
mir dass der Kanzler da nicht nur
deutlicher würde sondern eben auch das
einhält was er zugesagt hat dass wir an
der Seite derer stehen die unsere Hilfe
brauchen Europa Wahlkampf mit Betonung
auf Kampf vorrangig geht es am 9 juni um
Stimmen für Europa innenpolitisch aber
um die Zukunft beider
Parteien ja dann schnell ein paar Fragen
an den der den Europawahlkampf der SPD
verantwortet für Kevin küert ist es der
erste große Wahlkampf als
Generalsekretär Herr küert schön guten
Abend guten Abend her siwas auf den
Plakaten zur Europawahl also auch Olaf
Scholz obwohl man ihn gar nicht wählen
kann und obwohl er mit desaströsen um
Sympathiewerten und umfrageerten kämpft
wie wollen Sie denn davon Zugpferd
sprechen sowohl Katharina balele als
auch Olaf Scholz wer eine wichtige Rolle
in dieser Kampagne spielen und ich
möchte ihn ganz klar sagen warum weil
wir ein wahrhaftiges Politikangebot an
die Menschen machen wollen die wissen
nämlich europäische Politik ist
kompliziert es gibt das Parlament die
Kommission und die nationalen Regierung
und viele erleben Europa so dass da
immer alle durcheinander quatschen was
wir deutlich machen werden in unserem
Wahlkampf ist Sozialdemokratin und
Sozialdemokraten in Deutschland in
Berlin wie auch in Brüssel ziehen am
selben Strang Bali und Scholz stehen
gleichermaßen für bessere Löhne in
Europa für bezahlbarere Energiepreise
für ein Mindeststeuersatz bei
Unternehmen damit wir nicht alle leiden
müssen unter steuerd und andere mehr da
können sich die Wählerinnen und Wähler
bei uns drauf verlassen ich weiß nicht
ob die CDU auch Friedrich Merz und Ola
vonlein zusammen Plakatieren könnte ohne
dass das ganz schön viel Streit gäbe
wenn der Kanzler zur Europawahl auf den
Wahlplakaten erscheint ist das dann
nicht gerade zu auch einer Einladung
diese Wahl als Denkzettel zu nutzen für
die Berliner
Politik ich kann niemanden bevormunden
wenn Menschen meinen das tun zu müssen
dann müssen sie das tun ich glaube das
wäre ziemlich kurz gesprungen denn die
Wahlperiode ist 5 Jahre mit einer
Denkzettel Wahl egal gegenüber wem kann
man sich genau für einen Abend
Befriedigung verschaffen und danach wird
man 5 Jahre lang regiert von Leuten
deren Politik man überhaupt gar nicht
bestellt hat es geht um so viel Frau
Weidel hat doch gerade die Katze aus dem
Sack gelassen sie will mit der AFD ein
Vote über den deckit sie will in einem
Land bei dem jeder fünfte Arbeitsplatz
an der EU hängt und jedes zweite
Exportgut in die EU-Staaten geht will
sie aus der Europäischen Union raus
darüber wird abgestimmt da kann man
jetzt natürlich ein Votum über die
deutsche Bundesregierung abgeben aber
ich persönlich glaube es geht was
anderes es gibt jetzt schon 200 Parteien
und Wählergruppen im Europäischen
Parlament unglaublich viel
Meinungsvielfalt ich glaube man muss die
stark machen die kompromissbereit sind
und dort auch an Lösung arbeiten wollen
Herr Kön das was sie glauben in allen
Ehren gucken wir vielleicht mal ganz
kurz zurück letzte Europawahl
15,8% für die SPD das bis dato
schlechteste Ergebnis in ihrer
Geschichte bei einer bundesweiten Wahl
danach ist Andrea nales als Partei und
Fraktionschefin zurückgetreten wenn die
SPD das jetzt unterbieten S sollte kann
der Kanzler dann einfach weitermachen
wir können jetzt natürlich viereinhalb
Monate Wahlkampf überspringen und so tun
als sei das Ergebnis schon da aber ich
guck mir auch Umfragen an aber die sind
keine Wahlergebnisse wir kämpfen für ein
besseres ergeb K aber die die Umfragen
als eine aktuelle Umfrage sieht die SPD
zur Europawahl bei 9%. ja aber Herr sias
ich möchte ihn als Zeitzeuge dessen was
2019 passiert ist eines ganz deutlich
sagen die SPD aus dem Frühjahr 2019 die
gibt es nicht mehr das ist eine Partei
gewesen die nach innen morsch gewesen
ist eine Partei die unsolidarisch
miteinander umgegangen ist und die sich
nicht vertraut hat das hat übrigens bei
weitem nicht nur mit Andrea nales schon
gar nicht vorne weg zu tun gehabt das
haben wir hinter uns gelassen und eine
Menge Aufräumarbeiten gemacht wir
wollten und werden nie wieder so werden
wie damals wer sich Solidarität auf
seine Plakate raufchreibt das tut die
SPD hat eines zu tun nämlich nach außen
wie nach innen auch solidarisch
aufzutreten und deswegen stehen wir
geschlossen wir gewinnen Wahlen zusammen
und dann wenn uns der Wind ins Gesicht
steht dann stehen wir auch zusammen da
da können sich alle verlassen
Solidarität mnen sie an dann hören wir
heute die SPD Entschuldigung die FDP
Spitzenkandidatin und die sagt mit Blick
auf die ukrainehilfe über Olaf Scholz
insofern ist er nicht mein Kanzler
obwohl sie ja mit ihm in der Koalition
ist ist denn das Motto jetzt jeder gegen
jeden und alle gegen alle na das ist ja
eine bemerkenswerte Aussage also einmal
das tut mir jetzt leid für Frau
stckzimmermann ist Olaf Scholz natürlich
ihr Bundeskanzler er ist nämlich der
Kanzler aller deutschen das kann man
sich ja nicht nach Tagesstimmung
aussuchen und zweitens bin ich
insbesondere erstaunt über die Aussage
in dem Zusammenhang der ukrainehilfen
Frau Strack Zimmermann fordert seit zwei
Jahren so ziemlich jede Waffe die schon
mal gebaut wurde in die Ukraine zu
liefern und übersieht vollkommen dass
Deutschland mittlerweile der zweitgrößte
hilfengeber nach den USA ist und dass
der von ihr so kritisierte Bundeskanzler
in diesen Tagen gerade die europäischen
Partner die häufig große Bilder
produzieren in Kiev aber wenig Hilfe
liefern dass der die Partner dazu
aufruft endlich ihren Worten Taten
folgen zu lassen sie sollte stolz sein
sein da drauf dass dieser Bundeskanzler
es ernst meint mit der Hilfe und die
Solidarität der anderen einzufordern
aber wenn Sie sich dazu entscheidet
ihren Wahlkampf für die Europawahl gegen
den eigenen Bundeskanzler und die
Regierung bestreiten zu wollen dann kann
ich nur sagen viel Freude damit wir
werden uns auf dieses Niveau nicht
herabbegeben okay also da ist auch so
ein bisschen Europawahlkampf innerhalb
der Berliner Regierungskoalition Herr
küert Kevin küer der SPD Generalsekretär
ich danke herzlich für das Gespräch sehr
gern danke schön ja und dann gucken wir
auf eine Wahl heute die vergleichsweise
viel viel kleiner ist sale Orla Kreis
knapp 80.000 Einwohner Autokennzeichen
sok lbs PN und
scz das ist keine Metropolregion aber
eine mit gleich 15 Naturschutzgebieten
und eine die heute bundesweit
Aufmerksamkeit bekommt weil dieses Land
wissen will wer der neue Landrat im Sale
orer Kreis wird die AFD hatte sich
ausgerechnet dort ihre bundesweit
zweiten Landratsposten zu erringen vor z
Stunden das Ergebnis es hat nicht
geklappt Daniela
Sonntag auch wenn die AFD versucht alles
zu übertönen Christian hergort ist der
neue CDU Landrat im Sale orkreis beerbt
seinen Parteifreund die CDU verteidigt
das Schleizer Landratsamt knapp ich
freue mich dass ich die Wahl hier im
sakreis für mich entscheiden konnte aber
eins ist wichtig ich möchte ein Landrat
sein der für alle Menschen in diesem
Landkreis da ist auch für die die heute
nicht so wah gegangen sind und auch
diejenigen die mir heute nicht ihre
Stimme gegeben haben kein zweiter blauer
Landkreis die AFD reagiert
trotzig Kandidat Uwe Trum war nach dem
ersten Wahlgang noch siegessicher und
sie trotz der Niederlage seine Partei im
aufwiind die Kampagnen die gegen meine
Partei und meine Person geführt wurden
diese unmenschlichen Kampagnen haben uns
ja hier in Thüringen eher noch mal
gestärkt sie sehen dass wir auch der
stichwah noch mal zulegen konnten mit
Kampagnen meint Trum auch die Proteste
gegen Rechts zuletzt am Freitag gegen
einen Bürgerdialog mit börn höcke in
kleindmbach das Bündnis dorfliebe aus
dem Kreis war dabei insgesamt mehr gegen
Demonstranten als erwartet auch wenn
gegen die AFD zu sein hier nicht so
einfach ist halt trotzdem einfach ein
bisschen schwieriger hier auf dem Land
da einfach auches zu zeigen und ja es
ist trotzd
ein
schlussendlich um sich zurückzulehnen
und jetzt einfach zu sagen Bo cool in 6
Jahren wieder das da sind wir auf jeden
Fall weit davon entfernt halbe halbe
zwei Lager hier im ländlichen Thüringen
ist die Stimmung zerrissen viel
politisches Vertrauen verschwunden mehr
als die Hälfte der Einwohner ist über 50
der brottolohn liegt deutlich unterm
Landesschnitt zum Arbeiten wird viel
gependelt Berlin Erfurt die Politiker
dort werden sie nicht gesehen glauben
viele hier die Politik nimmt die
Landgebiete von uns nicht mit mit ihren
Tickets und so das betrifft alle unsere
Leute nicht das ist Benzin und sowas
Bauern AFD Mann Trum versprach im
Wahlkampf mehr zu tun für Schulen
Sportstätten Krankenhäuser die Probleme
vor der Haustür auch deshalb wirkt die
Partei für viele hier nicht extrem und
der Nachbar wählt sie doch auch die
Proteste dagegen bestärken viele in
dieser
Haltung das schade der AFD nicht im
Gegenteil es wird sogar nur noch mehr
Zulauf für der AFD geben alles
organisierter Dreck von diesen
sogenannten NGOs für mich ist die AFD
die Mitte ein Landrat für alle es wird
wohl ein harter Job und Sala war erst
der Auftakt im Mai geht es weiter mit
den Kommunalwahlen in
Thüringen ja eine echte Bewegung ist das
die auf Deutschlands Straßen unterwegs
ist und sich Gehör verschafft auch heute
Gundula ja auch an diesem Sonntag haben
in ganz Deutschland erneut mehr als
100.000 Menschen gegen das Erstarken der
extremen Rechten demonstriert
Schwerpunkt heute war Hamburg wo sich
nach Polizeiangaben mindestens 60.000
demonstrierende versammelten aufgerufen
von der Klimaschutzorganisation Fridays
for future und dutzenden Initiativen
auch in zahlreichen Städten gab es
Kundgebungen für Vielfalt und Demokratie
und gegen Rechtsextremismus
während Russland weiterhin die Ukraine
angreift Nacht für Nacht bestätigt sich
in der Ukraine ein massiver
Korruptionsfall bei der
Waffenbeschaffung verwickelt sein so der
ukrainische Geheimdienst hochrangige
Beamte des
Verteidigungsministeriums in Kiev und
Mitarbeiter eines ausländischen
Waffenlieferanten es geht um Granaten im
Wert von rund 40 Millionen Dollar das
Ministerium zahlte und die Waffen wurden
nie geliefert
über den neuen Präsidenten von Finnland
wird in einer Stichwahl in zwei Wochen
entschieden um die Nachfolge von
Amtsinhaber ninistö werden sich der
konservative ehemalige Ministerpräsident
stup und der grüne exaußenminister
havistow bewerben die heute die meisten
Stimmen erhielten keiner der insgesamt
neun Kandidaten erzielte die absolute
Mehrheit alle hatten eine harte Haltung
gegenüber Nachbarland Russland
angekündigt in Jordanien sind bei einem
Drohnenangriff drei US-Soldaten getötet
und Dutzende weitere verletzt worden
US-Präsident Biden erklärte der Anschlag
nahe der syrischen Grenze sei von
radikalen Gruppen verübt worden die vom
Iran unterstützt würden die USA würden
die Verantwortlichen zur Rechenschaft
ziehen in Jordanien sind rund 3000
US-Soldaten stationiert zuletzt wurden
vor allem US Stützpunkte im Irak und in
Syrien attackiert
die weltberühmte Mona Lisa im Pariser
Louvre war erneut Ziel von Vandalismus
zwei AktivistInnen die sich für
nachhaltige Ernährung engagieren
bewarfen das mit Panzerglas geschützte
Gemälde im Pariser Louvre mit Suppe die
sie in einer Thermoskanne für Kaffee
versteckt hatten die Frauen wurden
festgenommen der Louvre kündigte
strafanzeiger an zuletzt war im Mai 2022
das Schutzglas der Monalisa mit einer
Torte beschmiert
worden schon allein dass die Welt
überhaupt davon erfährt dass sich die
Geheimdienstchefs aus Israel Ägypten den
USA gerade treffen und der
Premierminister von Katar schon allein
das ist eine Nachricht da soll offenbar
etwas in Bewegung geraten in einem Krieg
der mit jedem weiteren Tag schwieriger
zu begründen ist US Regierungskreise
sähen jetzt Hoffnung auf einen
Durchbruch für Gaza und für Israel der
Plan sieht danach vor dass Hamas alle
Geiseln freilässt und Israel seinen
Militäreinsatz für zwei Monate stoppt es
wäre eine entscheidende Wende in einem
Konflikt der so viel Leid gebracht hat
und bringt wir reden dazu gleich
parallel findet heute in Jerusalem eine
bemerkenswerte Konferenz statt an der
gleich eine ganze Reihe von israelischen
Ministern teilnimmt es geht um Gaza nach
dem Krieg und ganz offen um eine Tat
Wiederbesiedlung durch Israel es geht
nicht um die Zukunft von 2 Millionen
Palästinensern dort lü
walpot es ist ein kalter verregneter
Wintertag in Jerusalem aber die Stimmung
in der Kongresshalle ist großartig
geradezu fiebrig 3000 Anhänger der
rechtsradikalen Siedlerbewegung sind da
die meisten aus dem israelisch besetzten
Westjordanland der Krieg in Gaza die
Terrorattacke der Hamas die Toten das
Leid hier in der Halle verdichtet sich
das alle zu einer aufbruchseuphorie Gaza
meine Heimat steht auf den T-Shirts Gaza
soll jüdisch besiedelt werden Besatzung
alleine reicht
nicht einen vollständigen Sieg erringen
wir erst wenn wir in den Häusern siedeln
von wo aus sie uns ermorden
wollten wer uns dabei nicht unterstützt
muss damit leben das ist unser Land
alles und wir sollten dort leben ja aber
was wird aus der arabischen Bevölkerung
in
Gaza sollen wo anders hin es gibt 22
arabische Länder wo sie glücklich leben
können wir wollen Sie hier
nicht extreme Meinungen derzeit wohl
nicht mehrheitsfähig in Israel aber eine
der Organisatorinnen der Konferenz
Daniela weiß gallionfigur der extremen
Siedler erinnert gerne daran dass auch
die Besiedlung des palästinensischen
Westjordanlands klein begann heute sind
wir 500.000 sagt sie die gaserkarte an
der Wand zeigt schon die geplanten
Siedlungen diese Konferenz ist nur der
Anfang so weiß
wir werden überall im Land Druck machen
dann wird Netanyahu sehen dass die
Bürger Israels keine Araber mehr in Gaza
akzeptieren nur Juden werden in Gaza
leben lange Zeit waren Siedler etwa 10%
der Bevölkerung eine Gruppe am
politischen rechten Rand doch ihre
Positionen werden zunehmend auch in der
Mitte bejubelt und sie haben mit
Finanzminister smotr und Polizeiminister
Ben Präsenz in der
Regierungskoalition uch sie für sein
politisches Überleben das wissen die
Fanatiker hier und Feiern uniert ihre
neue Stärke ihr Motto für Gaza besetzen
besiedeln
Siegen es ist jetzt die Zeit für mutige
Entscheidungen es ist die Zeit zurück
nach Hause zu kehren zurück nach
[Musik]
Israel Terroristen zu verhängen die Zeit
zu
[Applaus]
gewinnen Tod den Arabern Tod den
Terroristen Haltes dem sichtlich
erfreuten Minister entgegen moderate
Vorschläge konstruktive Lösungsansätze
bei diesen israelischen Bürgern war
dafür heute Abend in Jerusalem kein
Platz ja dann müssen noch mal sprechen
mit dem Chefredakteur des Fachmagazins
Zenit der hatte immer auch einen
interessanten Einblick hinter die
Kulissen der nahostdipomatie guten Abend
Daniel Gerlach ja guten Abend fangen wir
vielleicht erstmal an mit dieser
Konferenz die wir da gerade gesehen
haben also die Träume von manchen in
Israel nicht nur rechtsextremen auch
einigen offenbar aus Netanyahus
likutpartei Gaza zu besiedeln oder
vielleicht muss man eher sagen das was
mal Gaza war ist das jetzt tatsächlich
ein Plan der sich umsetzen ließe also es
wird ja ganz offen damit geworben mit
einer Villa am Strand von Gaza das ist
ein Traum dieser Leute und manche haben
sogar vorgeschlagen dass man den
Soldaten die in Gaza kämpfen äh als
Belohnung dafür Land zur Verfügung
stellen sollte also man muss das schon
ernst neehmen wenn der Minister für
nationale Sicherheit solche Reden auf
seiner solchen Konferenz schwingt das
Problem ist dass ich die israelische
Öffentlichkeit und ein Stück weit auch
die Weltmedien zu sehr daran gewöhnt
haben dass solche Reden geschwungen
werden und auch daran gewöhnt haben dass
man das nicht ernst nehmen soll das wird
ja auch immer wieder gesagt auch auch
von israelischen Regierungsmitgliedern
und ich denke man sollte es tatsächlich
ernst nehmen was da gesagt wird und
sollte die Gefahr ernst nehmen auch wenn
ich persönlich nicht glaube dass diese
dieser wiederbesiedlungsplan von Gaza
durch durch jüdische Siedler stattfinden
wird denn er bräuchte er würde sehr sehr
viel Aufwand bedeuten sehr sehr viel
Sicherheitsinfrastruktur bedeuten und
ich glaube auch ein Teil der
israelischen Öffentlichkeit hat die Nase
voll für solche Leute den Kopf
hinzuhalten wie sie es in der
Vergangenheit getan hat dann reden wir
über das was ich eingangs gesagt hatte
Geheimdienstler die sich treffen und
einen Durchbruch ausloten wollen
Freilassung aller Geiseln gegen zwei
Monate Waffenruhe welche Chance hat
sowas in
Gaza na offensichtlich heute wurde ja
bekannt gegeben aus israelischen
Regierungskreisen dass diese Gespräche
konstruktiv seien und dass man ein
Strück weit vorangekommen sei die
technische Implementierung die
technische Umsetzung glaube ich von
solchen Plänen die ist tatsächlich
möglich und es hängt natürlich ein Stück
weit davon ab ob z.B die arabische Seite
also die die Ägypter und die Kataris
ausreichend Druck auf die Hamas ausüben
können um eben stillzuhalten um sich
einem solchen Plan auch zu beugen und
auch Kompromisse einzugehen aber ich
sehe ein anderes Problem und das ist
eigentlich im Gefüge zwischen den
verhandelnden Parteien dem Chef des
israelischen Auslandsgeheimdienstes
mossat David barnea dem Vertrauen die
Verhandlungsführer das gilt für die USA
für Ägypten und für die qataris
seinem Vorgesetzten Ben Netanyahu
vertrauen Sie nicht und das ist ein
erhebliches Problem denn auch jetzt ist
wieder aus den unterhändlerkreisen zu
hören dass man fürchtet dass Netanyahu
diese Verhandlungen in letzter Minute
dann sabotieren wolle das ist deren
Aussage nicht meine Analyse
notwendigerweise aber trotzdem wichtig
zu verstehen um eben von ein einen
solchen Deal zum Scheitern zu bringen
und um den Krieg fortzusetzen um eben
seine Machtposition zu bewahren und auch
das israelische kabinettsgefüge derzeit
nicht zu gefährden denn wenn er das
tatsächlich dazu kommen sollte dass eine
Waffenruhe in ein Ende des Krieges
übergeht dann könnte es eben mit seiner
Regierung vorbei sein und dann könnten
Neuwahlen anstehen und dieser
Interessenkonflikt der ist wichtig zu
verstehen wenn man die Frustration und
auch ja die die inneren Konflikte unter
den Verhandlungsführern e ausreichend
analysieren möchte also einiges an
Hoffnung aber auch noch sehr sehr sehr
viele Fragen und Unwegbarkeiten Daniel
gerler herzlichen Dank für diese Analyse
heute Abend live bei uns ja sehr
gern und dann machen wir jetzt hier in
der Sendung einen Schnitt würde ich mal
sagen es gibt nämlich auch noch eine
ganze Menge Sport an diesem Sonntag
gundola ja wir beginnen mit den
Sonntagsspielen in der Fußball
buundesliga borussia Dortmund hat den
VfL Bochum besiegt 3:1 Dortmund damit
auf tabell Platz 4 zuvor hatte Union
Berlin ohne den gesperrten Trainer
bieliza einen wichtigen Heimsieg im
Abstiegskampf geholt 1:0 gegen
tabellenchlusslich Darmstadt 98 Union
Berlin jetzt auf Platz 15 der Tabelle
Tennisprofi Jannick Sinner hat mit
seinem Sieg bei den Australian Open
enormen Jubel in seinem Heimatland
Italien ausgelöst der erst 22-jährige
hatte sich nach starker Aufholjagt in
fünf Sätzen gegen den Russen Daniel
medwedev durchgesetzt für Sinne ist es
der erste Grand Slam Titel und der
bislang größte Erfolg seiner jungen
Karriere bei der Rodel WM im sächsischen
Altenberg hat das deutsche Team
insgesamt sieben Medaillen geholt die
Weltcup führende Julia taubitz gewann
Silber im einsitze und gold mit der
Teamstaffel gemeinsam mit Tobias wendel
Tobias
max langenhana alberger und SAS Schirmer
bescherte sie dem scheidenden
Bundestrainer Norbert Loch ein goldenes
WM
Finale auch beim Bob Weltcup dominieren
die deutschen Sportler im norwegischen
Lillehammer besiegten siegten im Zweier
Bob Kim kaliki und Leonie fieich ganz
knapp vor Laura Nolte und n Schuten
Doppelerfolg auch für die Männer im
Viererbob geht das Duell zwischenco und
Johannes Lochner weiter mit 22 h
Sekunden Vorsprung vor Lochner landete
Friedrich heute auf Platz 1 beide aber
Friedrich und Lochner konnten bereits
jeweils drei Saisonsiege
feiern himmelhoch jauchzend zu Tode
betrübt für Fans der großen Emotionen
hat die deutsche
Handballnationalmannschaft definitiv
abgeliefert bei der heimem erst aber
Millionen vor den Fernseher gezogen mit
ihrem Spiel dann heute das direkte
Ticket für Olympia und die
Bronzemedaille verpasst was man nach den
tollen Tagen im Turnier aber bereits
sagen kann die handballem hat schon mal
einiges von dem gezeigt was sich ein
ganzes Land jetzt von der Fußball EM
erhofft Tibor mein Gast mit mehr
Enttäuschung dominiert nach der vierten
Niederlage in ihrem neun und letzten
emspiel sie ziehen den Hut vor denen die
besser
sind deutschen von Bronze zu wenige
Varianten im Angriff und zu viele Fehler
für einen weltklassegegner wie die
Schweden gegen die Topnationen der Welt
können sie nur phasenweise mithalten
dass man das Gefühl hatte e die
deutschen kämpfen sie sind dran aber
schaffen es vielleicht nicht ganz und
das ist das der Status Quo es steckt
ungeheuer viel Energie in Knorr Köster
und Co in der Begegnung mit Island
unübersehbar kampfkräftig einsatzfreudig
diszipliniert getragen vom
enthusiastischen Publikum gelegentlich
blitzt sogar Spielintelligenz auf wie
beim souveränen Auftritt gegen Ungarn
aber insgesamt zu selten im Halbfinale
gegen Weltmeister Dänemark eine tolle
erste Hälfte Deutschlands aber doch eine
Niederlage allerdings mit positiven
Aspekten mit unsere junge Truppe sind
haben wir riesen Schritte nach vorne
gemacht und ich glaube
schon viele viele Meter sind näher
rangekommen an an an die Top
3 im Spiel um Platz 3
sie am schwedischen Torwart Andreas PAL
und ihr Chancenverwertung eine verkorte
erste Spielhälfte danach eine zwar
imponierende aber nicht erfolgreiche
Aufholjagd junge ren uskin glänzt beim
31 z34 mit Treffer und analysiert die
deutschen Defizite so vielleicht F
Qualität vielleicht ist einfach eben
noch diese
leistungstellener Spiel oder eine junge
mannscha Qualifikation im Frühjahr aber
hat das Team noch eine zweite Chance der
Bundestrainer ganz
hoffnungsvoll ich bin sehr optimistisch
für diese mcha der aber schon noch was
fehlt im Vergleich zu Frankreich das
durch ein 33 Z 31 im Finale gegen
Dänemark Europameister
wird 14 14 juni beginnt die fußballem in
Deutschland noch knapp 5
monateing morgen beginnt erstmal eine
neue Woche und auf die guckt jetzt Laura
[Musik]
bahnik nachdem auch die dritte
Verhandlungsrunde im Tarifkonflikt
zwischen dem Marburger Bund und der
Tarifgemeinschaft deutscher Länder
erfolglos war werden am Dienstag
Ärztinnen und Ärzte der Unikliniken
bundesweit streiken sie kämpfen für mehr
Lohn und bessere
Arbeitsbedingungen am Mittwoch ist es
exakt vier Jahre her dass das Vereinigte
Königreich die EU verlassen hat nach
mehr als 40 Jahren Mitgliedschaft der
brexit kostete Großbritannien 2023 mehr
als 122 Milliarden Euro die
wirtschaftliche Lage hat sich enorm
verschlechtert grund dafür sind unter
anderem der nun erschwerte Handel mit
der EU und die dadurch gestiegenen
Lebensmittelpreise der EU-Sondergipfel
am kommenden Donnerstag war bereits im
Dezember von EU-Ratspräsident Michelle
angekündigt worden dabei werden die
Staats- und Regierungschef erneut über
ein neues 50 Milliarden Euro Paket für
die Ukraine verhandeln dies war bisher
am Widerstand Ungarns
gescheitert und das Wetter in der neuen
Woche bringt hier zulande milde
Temperaturen und viel Sonne nur im
Norden und in der Mitte können hohe
Wolken den Sonnenschein trüben der Nebel
im Süden sollte sich bis Mittag
aufgelöst haben bei 6 bis 14° am
Dienstag wird es ähnlich am Mittwoch im
Norden am Donnerstag auch im Süden Regen
milde 6 bis
13° okay also bis Mittwoch gucke ich mir
den Wetterbericht gerne an vielen Dank
im Namen von allen Kolleginnen und
Kollegen auch den hinter den Kameras
sagen wir zwei danke für Ihr Interesse
das war das infoangebot der heute
journalredaktion ja und ab morgen sind
hier Marietta Slomka und Heinz Wolf für
Sie
da willst du noch sagen ja immer aktuell
informiert sind auf ZDF heute und später
gegen 0:30 Uhr mit einer heute Express
das darf nicht fehlen jetzt aber einen
angenehmen Abend mach es gut tschüss
[Musik]
tschüss